the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care if he's a bastard
that starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight prediction video today I
wanted to talk about Howlin Reed some of
you are always asking me questions about
him so I figured it was time to make a
video about this character that is
shrouded in mystery as I'm sure most of
you know Howland Reed is the father of
Meera and Jojen Reed and he is one of
Ned Stark's most loyal bannermen Howland
Reed is a very interesting character but
we don't know a whole lot about him in
fact his name only appears 13 times
throughout all five books India Song of
Ice and Fire series many fans have asked
george RR martin about this character
and whether or not we would see him
again
George has said that Howland Reed would
have an important role in the books to
come but the main reason why we don't
see Howland Reed early in the story is
because he knows too much critical
information if Alan Reed showed up in
the first book he would be able to
provide some of the answers to this
story's greatest mysteries and those
things cannot be revealed just yet now
that this story is coming close to its
end we may be seeing him again next
season but where is he at and what has
he been doing all of this time what we
do know is Howland Reed was with Ned
during one of the most important moments
in this entire story when Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen disappeared
everyone assumed Rhaegar had to have
abducted Lyanna and this led to Ned's
father and brother going to King's
Landing to have a little talk with the
Mad King but this did not end well for
either one of them the Mad King had both
of them killed after the sack of King's
Landing in the siege of storms end
Howlin and five other Northman accompany
Ned Stark south to the red mountains in
search of Leona Helen Reed and Ned Stark
were the only survivors of the combat at
the Tower of joy between the seven
Northman
and the three Knights of the Kingsguard
Ned later told bran stark that Howland
had saved his life from Sir Arthur Dayne
who was known as one of the deadliest
swordsmen at that
time NED then finds Liana inside of the
tower laying in a bed of blood he was
with her as she died and Howland was the
one who found men still holding Liana
and he was the person who took Leon his
hand from ned's during Game of Thrones
season 6 we found out exactly what
happened at the Tower of joy Ned was
there to rescue Liana
but the King's Guard were not about to
allow him to enter the tower so they had
to fight to the death during the fight
Sir Arthur Dayne was able to disarm Ned
Stark and he was moments away from
delivering the fatal blow
that was until Howland Reed came up
behind him and shoved the dagger into
his neck this allowed Ned Stark to get
back to his feet and finish him off with
his own sword when Ned finds Liana
inside of the tower she is barely
clinging to life but before she dies she
has Ned promise her one thing and that
is to protect her son Jon Snow Ned had
to live with this secret for the rest of
his life because of Robert Baratheon had
ever found out who John truly was he
would have had him killed
so Ned took the secret to his grave as
of right now bran stark and Samuel Tarly
are the only other people who know that
Jon Snow is actually Aegon Targaryen the
true heir to the Iron Throne but how
many people would actually believe their
story
everything that brain has seen was seen
during a vision which makes it kind of
hard to prove to other people who
weren't there and the information Sam
found out only mentions a private
wedding it doesn't say anything about a
child this could mean that Howland Reed
may be the only person alive that could
testify that Jon Snow is not Ned's
illegitimate son but he's actually the
child of Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen because of course Howland Reed
was there and he may even have the scars
to prove it because he was also injured
in the battle at the Tower of joy this
could definitely back up Brants claim
about who Jon Snow truly is but the big
question still remains where the hell is
Howland Reed where has he been all of
this time and why has he never shown his
face in the Starks most desperate time
of need when he is said to be one of
their most loyal bannermen Howland Reed
wasn't there when Robb Stark was named
King and
north and he wasn't there when John Snow
was named king in the north either now I
know this is something that fans have
been wondering for quite some time
because some of you have even asked me
this question yourself one of the few
mentions of Howland Reed was when we
meet his children
Jojen and Meera I could not find this
scene in the show but in the books we
learned that Howland sent his children
to Winterfell after Jojen tells him of
his dream about the winged wolf and the
three-eyed crow there isn't any evidence
that Howland Reed has green cider green
dreams but he was aware of his sons
abilities and this led him to sending
his children to what they're felt to
look after bran we also know that jochem
was the one who informed Howland Reed of
Ned Stark's death because Jojen tells
Bryan how his father reacted to the news
when I
told my father about your father the
first time in my life I saw him cry
your father is Howland Reed saved my
father's life during the rebellion
father told you about the rebellion even
though we don't have any evidence of
Howland Reed having green dreams or
greensight this doesn't mean he isn't
capable of having these powers we
already know Howlin Reed is great at
keeping a secret so perhaps he has some
abilities of his own and he has chosen
to keep this a secret as well one very
interesting detail about Howland Reed is
when he was around let's say the age of
16 he decided to go on a little
adventure to seek out more knowledge
about the green men and the Isle of
faces before the infamous tourney at
Harrenhal what set emotionally on a
stark and rhaegar relationship Howland
Reed traveled to the Isle of faces to
meet with the green man he was there for
a whole winter but what secrets he
learned to remain unknown it was after
he left the gods eye when his close
friendship with the Starks began but
that might have just been a coincidence
there could be a specific reason Howland
Reed was able to spend so much time with
the green men because as a kradic man of
the neck he might have a special
connection with them the Isle of faces
is a sacred place where one of the most
important events in Westeros is history
occurred the Isle of faces is one of the
last remaining places in the south of
Westeros where one can find weirwood
trees the where woods all have faces
carved into them from the time of the
first men one day and the children made
the pact the faces were made so that the
gods could witness it it is also said to
be the home of the green man the green
men tend to the trees and are said to be
a source of insightful wisdom stories
claim that they have green skin and
antlers like deer but may stars believe
they simply wear green clothes and wear
horned headdresses it might also be
where the last children of the forest
are living and I'm dying to know what
Howland Reed found out while he was
there I think it is possible that he
became friends with Ned and Liana by
chance but perhaps he found out some
information from the children that sent
him on a path of becoming intertwined
with the star
perhaps Howland Reed went to the Olive
faces to awaken his own third eye maybe
he was there practicing and learning how
to use his own powers this could be what
led him to attend the tourney at
Harrenhal as he had seen in his dreams
what may happen and how he has to be a
part of the events or the children of
the forest could have just told him
either way I don't think it's just a
coincidence the Howland Reed visited the
Isle of faces then after he left these
chain of events unfolded he must know
something which also makes sense why his
son Jojen would also be given this power
when mirror Reed is telling bran the
story about her father she says he could
breathe mud and run on leaves and change
earth to water and water to earth with
no more than a whispered word he could
talk to trees and weave words and make
castles appear and disappear the lad
knew the magics of the chronic man but
one and more I don't know about you but
that sounds pretty damn impressive and
it sounds like something that could be
useful when the wars to come this might
sound crazy but can you imagine if
Howland Reed showed up during the Great
War and he had an army of the chosen of
the forest and green men from the Isle
of faces all armed with dragonglass
weapons and magic that is capable of
breaking the arm of Dorne this could
make for one hell of an official
introduction for Howland Reed we are led
to believe he is still at his home in
the neck but I don't think anyone knows
if that's true or not we know Catelyn
and raw both sent letters to Howland
Reed but I don't remember them actually
receiving any word back Meera Reed
assumes her father was still there
because when she left brand she told him
she was going home to be with her family
maester wolkan built it to me so I can
move around more easily it's a very good
idea you're leaving
I don't want to leave you but when when
they come I need to be with my family
you're safe in my opinion Mira made it
sound like her and her family would stay
at home when the White Walkers come but
I can't imagine them not playing some
part in the Great War
I believe Howland Reed has been helping
from the very beginning of the story and
even before the current story he's
helping with the long night that's why
he sent his kids to get brand to the
three-eyed Raven he knows what is coming
and I hope he has a plan of his own
prepared when and if Howland Reed
appears in the show next season
I think whatever chosen or the forest or
green men that are left at the Isle of
faces will also be involved in some way
and I would love to see all of them play
a part in the final battle against the
night king I know some people believe
the Great War will land at the Isle of
faces but I'm not so sure about that
however I do think if brain stark
survives the war this is where he will
spend the remainder of his life but I
don't want to go down that rabbit hole
in this video let me know what you think
will happen next season I know everyone
always talks about Howlin Reed's showing
up to tell John the truth about his
parents but what else could you see him
doing and where do you think he has been
do you believe he could be at the Isle
of faces as we speak and do you think he
could show up with his own army of green
men and children of the forest put all
your thoughts down below I want to thank
everyone for watching the video I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
all of my supporters on patreon may the
old gods and the new look over each and
every one of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you